hey guys it is much the temple my name
is Jess and here's the gaming news of
today a brand new Pokemon mobile game
has been announced it's called Pokemon
Co master and will be out in Japan later
this year the free-to-play game mixes
elements of traditional Pokemon titles
with strategy elements from games like
chess and go a short trailer was
released by developer harrah's which
shows off squads of Pokemon Biggers
facing off against each other on either
end of a game board although no further
details have been revealed there seems
to be an AI element to the game designed
to help players a Western release has
not yet been confirmed if you didn't
pre-order Wolfenstein the new order but
you'd like to get your hands on the doom
beta your local gamestop could have you
slaughtered the retailer have announced
that beginning april one at 6pm EST
anyone who shows up at the store and
asks for a code will receive one of
course the codes will be in limited
supply so you'll want to get in early if
you're keen for one the gamestop codes
will be available on ps4 xbox one and pc
the closed multiplayer beta runs from
March 31 to april 3 and doom is due to
hit shelves on me 13 The Witcher
developer stutter project red has talked
up their upcoming RPG cyberpunk 2077 as
well as explaining their plans for
future games according to jewel shocker
studio head Adam Badowski sand that
cyberpunk will be even better even
bigger and even more revolutionary than
what they had originally planned given
the scope and success of the witcher 3
he insisted that while the game is a
long way of launch it's a much bigger
game than the witcher and the dev have
quote amazingly large ambitions for it
to produce such a monster the studio
plans to at least double its staff which
presently sits at around 400 people
although not all of those will work on
cyberpunk 2077 elsewhere in today's
earnings briefing the damned announced
that they plan to release a new game in
2016 said approach explained that it
would be quote a new type of video game
format previously unexplored by the
studio another slide in the presentation
indicated that the studio also plan to
release another triple a RPG
title somewhere between 20 17 and 20 21
let me know down in that comment section
where you'd like to see set a fright red
work on next you can add against all
we've got stories on the borderlands
movie and division 2 that is everything
I hope you today but let me know what
you cared about and showing the same
time tomorrow from the biggest stories
of the whole week